Let's go back a little to the colonial
era because this is really what you're
describing. Islam stays dominant and
you're right. Uh people forget that
Islam, especially the Ottoman Empire was
the powerhouse. It's ingrained in
people's mind as if Europe was always
super powerful and everyone else all
these brown people were just being
abused and scared of Europe. It was the
opposite, okay, as as we discussed. But
especially with the rise of the Ottomans
and these guys last from, you know,
1300s to the 1900s and in 1683 they're
in Vienna, okay, with 2 to 300,000
fighters surrounding it. So I mean, so
keep that in mind. We started off in the
600s with Muhammad and the first attack
on Christian territory in 636. 1683, now
we're talking a thousand years later.
they're around Vienna and uh they're
using the same logic and rationale and
they're talking about Islam and jihad
and you have three choices etc etc okay
and it's not even just at 1683 to bring
it to this country the United States its
very first war as a nation in uh in the
as a nation meaning after independence
from Britain
>> no need to rub it in
>> yeah I was trying to word it correctly
here but um uh after that uh and now
it's its own country its first war is
with Muslims the Barbar wars and again
they're acting exactly on the same logic
and Thomas Jefferson this great paragon
of enlightened thinking uh didn't know
Islam as well as he should have because
when he met with what the Barbary
parties start doing is actually attack
so this is very interesting because it
goes back to the idea of Jiza so a lot
of these European powers and I'll get to
I'll get to your point but I'm just
trying to build it up to show you what
happened but a lot of these European
powers instead of fighting with the
Barbrey Muslim pirates of North Africa
whose entire economy
consisted of slave raids on Europeans as
far as Iceland they would go and enslave
them. Uh started just paying them off
which the Muslims took as Jiza tribute.
Okay. Now when the US uh the United
America broke away from Britain, it was
no longer covered by Britain's Jiza
payments. And once the Muslims found
that out, they started attacking
American vessels in the Atlantic and in
the Mediterranean and enslaving them and
engaging all sorts of horrific, you
know, abuses against them. I talk a lot
about that in one of my books, Sword and
Scimitar. Actually, I have a whole
chapter about it. Um, because if you
really read about what was happening to
European slaves, including these
American ones, it was really sick stuff.
Anyway, so that's what provoked the
first war of America with the Barbrey.
But when Jefferson and John Adams met,
they tried to, you know, find a
diplomatic solution. So, they met with
um one of the ambassadors from Barbrey
AB Abdul something. And um he they say
to him, "Hey, why can't we just have
peaceful trade and work together, etc."
typical Americans. And uh he basically
he he sounds like an ISIS guy. He goes,
"Our prophet and our holy book says you
are the infidel. You're the enemy. And
it's our right to plunder, kill, and
enslave you until you acknowledge Allah
alone." Okay. So my point is uh just to
give you a sort of totality. We started
in the 600s. This is now 1800. First war
of America. Same mentality, same logic.